all right so Kaleidoscope is an unusual
Heist Thriller that might seem familiar
Until you realize the series has a trick
up its sleeve you can watch the series
in like any order to see water-soaked
actors and seriously intense vaults no
wonder the shoot was so chaotic so your
first day as a director on a new series
is underwater and you have half a day to
prepare good freaking luck Russell fine
explained that that's exactly what
happened to him when he tried to prepare
for the White episode on his first day
thankfully he was a cinematographer
before getting into directing and knew
how to plan each shot even though I
didn't have a lot of time to prep I did
very extensive shot diagrams so using
two conventional cameras an underwater
cameraman and a scuba team fine was able
to capture different angles making the
show feel super immersive actor
Giancarlo Esposito who plays The Heist
Mastermind made finds job even easier by
performing his own stunts underwater
there was a speaker for the actor
underwater which meant Esposito could
self-roll cut and hear any directions
needed you have no idea how important
that is Kaleidoscope set up one of the
most elaborate vaults we've ever seen
the show has Bandits trying to leak just
a little bit of water into the Vault
using the water main as the source but
since they're all a little pressed for
time pulling a heist and all it turned
into a brutal flood this scene was so
complex it required a special set for
the crew to be able to easily maneuver
around and it needed to be filled with
water of course the director Russell
fine explained when you walk in the set
there's these two huge water tanks and
it was like a swimming pool they could
turn on the water and it just starts
filling up and comes through the ceiling
Rosaline elbe one of the actors said
we'd see the big water tanks being built
outside the Netflix Studios knowing that
they were going to flood the set the
entire episode itself took what elbe
called a soggy soggy six weeks so what
makes this show unique is that the
episodes are designed to be watched in
any order while it might be fun for
viewers trying to keep the storyline
organized was way more challenging the
cast said making Kaleidoscope was like
trying to put a difficult puzzle
together but with the creative team
keeping track of all the moving Parts
the cast went with whatever came their
way when filming even if it made for a
confusing experience at the time actors
tati Gabrielle J Courtney and Rosaline
elbe all said they were all unaware of
the Creator Eric Garcia's plan for the
show at first Giancarlo Esposito however
knew early on after being sent a few
versions of the script Esposito found
the concept fascinating I was intrigued
by that but more interested in how it
would all link up and how I would be
able to use those links and clues to
deepen my performance it was more like
shooting a movie than a series honestly
tati Gabrielle felt that the non-linear
structure was I think incredibly freeing
as an actor and just really fun to go
through as for Jay Courtney things got
seriously confusing I had moments as an
actor where I was like wait but didn't
we just jump out of the building it's
like no that's in a couple weeks time
when Gathering inspiration for creating
this Heist Thriller the Creator Eric
Garcia pulled inspiration from other
Heist films the fact is Heist crime
Mafia that world is my favorite stuff
one of his biggest Inspirations though
was the 1955 French crime film which has
a 30 minute long break in dialogue while
the thieves attempt to break open a
vault sound familiar in the white
episode's opening sequence there's no
dialogue for the first 11 minutes while
the thieves do their work to get into
the vault in order to bring this Vision
to life and ensure viewers could start
at any episode and immediately like
understand the story and its characters
Garcia had to create a lot of Master
plans that focused on things like
narrative props and the script to piece
it together it really did take a village
I had to group about 10 people in my
writer's rooms everybody in the room
worked together and we had a ton of
whiteboards and a ton of note cards he
said it was thanks to people like the
production Designer Michael Bricker the
props designer Max Sherwood and the
costume designer Jenny gearing that they
were able to make the show work they
actually were excited by the crazy
process would you be how would you
tackle it Kaleidoscope story may seem
very specific and maybe even familiar so
what inspired the White episode
Hurricane Sandy raged through the
Caribbean and U.S east Coast causing
around
81.9 billion in Damages it wasn't just
the physical destruction that racked up
the dollars though during the storm 70
billion in bearer bonds were lost in a
flood and Garcia knew the story would
make a very compelling Heist like in
real life there may not have been actual
thieves involved but both stories
involve lots of water so for Eric Garcia
it all just made sense that's a perfect
cover-up for a heist if I'm doing a
heist I'm going to use Hurricane Sandy
as my excuse so as it turns out
Kaleidoscope was just as thrilling for
the creators and the actors as it was
for us to watch what are some of your
favorite moments from this Heist
Thriller do you have a preferred order
to watch it in let us know in the
comments below